from the implications of immortality
granting will goop to Free Willy
tributes Avatar the way of water has an
ocean of small details you might have
missed
most of James Cameron's previous films
have an anti-capitalist or at least
anti-corporate stance within the film's
narrative in the previous Avatar film
this was shown through the banal but
nonetheless coldly malicious
machinations of the resources
development Administration or RDA as
they try to kill off all the navi
hostiles and hollow out the natural
resources of Pandora by enlisting a
paramilitary unit led by Stephen Lang's
Colonel Miles coach in avatar The Wave
water Colonel quartz returns as the
sequel film's main antagonist once again
the film explains away quartz's
Resurrection by stating that RDA had
stored his memories onto a disc prior to
the first film's mission in case he were
to die and since he did die at the end
of the first film his memories were put
into a Navy's Avatar to return to
Pandora and finished the mission he
started years earlier picks me up if I
rotate it back and make me pretty again
this brings up another example of the
evils of untethered capitalism and
corporate power in this dystopian future
you still have to work for the company
even after you die in avatar The Way of
water quirch now A navi doesn't seem too
disturbed by this Revelation himself
however the existential dread of how bad
the labor conditions on earth have to be
to allow infinite forced employment is
pretty horrifying
at one point the newly resurrected Navi
cloned version of Colonel korich returns
to the place where Jake Sully and
nateiri had killed him in his original
human form at the end of the first
Avatar film since many years have passed
since his death gorgeous human body has
now decomposed into a rotting skeleton
navarch then picks up his dead human
skull in an obvious reference to the
Alas poor Yorick monologue from Hamlet
this isn't just a simple visual illusion
either the speech is about the
existential dread of one's inevitable
death as well as the futility of life
itself Hamlet had fond memories of York
and as he holds York's skull in his hand
he laments what he sees as a waste of
life so too does courage as he holds his
own human head in his noun of the hands
he is literally seeing the futility of
his past life as well as the
inevitability of his own death since it
already happened he attempts to come to
terms with it but then decides to crush
the skull in an act of defiance to the
blatant symbolism of fate and the
natural order of the Life Death cycle
in the first avatar actor Giovanni
rabisi played the corporate villain
Parker Selfridge who was the head of the
earth-based RDA that was seeking
Pandora's sacred unobtainium he was
essentially the main antagonist of that
film alongside Stephen Lang's
aforementioned Colonel courage and in
many ways was worse than the colonel
Selfridge himself represented the banal
evils of bureaucratic corporate greed
yeah look you're supposed to be winning
the hearts in the minds of the natives
isn't that the whole point of your
little puppet show Ribisi Selfridge is
not a major character in the sequel but
he does have a blink and you'll miss a
cameo in it nonetheless his appearance
occurs towards the beginning of the film
while Colonel quartz has recently
awakened that V clone watches a
recording from his human self in the
past in the recording Selfridge is seen
in the background correcting courage and
detailing the technology behind the
memory transfer process when James
Cameron's original 2009 Avatar film was
first released in theaters one of the
chief complaints was that it was
basically Dances with Wolves but with
blue space aliens instead of Native
Americans both films are about soldier
from a colonizing Force going native by
falling in love with the indigenous
people and deciding to fight his own
kind to protect them furthermore both
films talk about how most native
cultures would use the entire animal
after a hunt utilizing the animal's meat
to eat their hide to make clothes their
bones to make tools Etc Avatar the way
of water unsurprisingly has many
breathtaking sequences in it one of the
most harrowing sequences in the film is
to chase scene on the Pandora notion
between a massive RDA hunting vessel and
a herd of sentient alien will like
creatures called Tolkien it's an obvious
solution to the inhuman and cruel
wailing practices as we see the RDA
hunting crew using their Advanced sci-fi
technology to violently Corner trap and
kill an entire family of Tolkien it's
also reminiscent of the way European
colonizers in the west would hunt
animals like the Buffalo to near
Extinction for their hides while letting
the corpses rot with no care for The
Wider ecosystem furthermore while the
giant Falcon are hunted mercilessly it's
only so that the company can extract
just one single vial of brain goop
leaving the rest of the talking
carcasses to rot what's interesting
about Avatar the way of water is that
besides some offhand Dimensions the plot
of the film is no longer predicated on
extracting an obtainium from Pandora
anymore instead the RDA is attempting to
completely terraform Pandora for human
occupation as in the ensuing years since
the first Avatar film it seems Earth has
become completely uninhabitable we don't
spend a lot of time on Earth but it
seems one of the main issues with the
planet in the Avatar universe is that
it's overcrowded see during the
previously mentioned Tolkien hunting
scene we discovered the Tolkien brain
goop is used to completely stop Aging in
humans this means that there is a
population of people on Earth who are
essentially Immortal assuming they can
afford the goop adding to the fact that
workers can seemingly have their
memories scanned to constantly be
recloned as an infinite labor force it
seems the company's short-sighted profit
motivated and anti-labor policies are
dooming Earth this also goes against the
balancing of energy that Navi follow on
Pandora they say the goddess airwa gives
energy for life but that it is only
borrowed and that you end up giving the
energy back in death however humans on
Earth presumably Rich humans are trying
to hoard their life and their energy and
not giving it back to Nature causing
disruption chaos and destruction on
their planet in the process
it's no secret that Avatar the way of
water director and co-redder James
Cameron is obsessed with the ocean he
spent tons of money from his own
personal Fortune to fund deep sea
Expeditions so it's no surprise that
some of that design aesthetic for the
rda's token hunting operations would
have some aesthetic similarities to real
ships and Subs even the more Fantastical
sci-fi designs such as the subs that
have metallic crab-like legs and
mechanical claws bare resemblances to
real Tech in the field of deep sea
diving James Cameron's love for the
ocean clearly extends to the various
Aquatic Life that inhabits it this
includes the whale-like Tolkien who live
in the ocean and visit the coastal
Villages of the marine-based mekayina
navi tribe nimakaina and Tolkien share a
close sacred Bond as the Tolkien
revealed to be sentient creatures
arguably smarter than both the humans
and Navi who are even capable of complex
language mathematics and even art at one
point Jake's younger son Loach befriends
a wounded and banished Tolkien
throughout the rest of the film Loach
and the banished Tolkien swim together
and grow a close and special bond
themselves the Tolkien even becomes
pivotal to the navi winning the final
battle against the large Tolkien hunting
ship this subplot seems to be similar to
the plot of the 1993 family film Free
Willy about a young boy who befriends a
mistreated Orca and then is able to free
it from captivity not only that but
there are seemingly overt visual
references to the film such as the slow
motion shot of it climactically jumping
in the air set right before Pandora's
daily eclipse that is very close to the
visuals of Free Willy's cinematography
the climax of avatar The Wave water is
set during a battle on top of the ocean
where the entire Sully family fights off
courage and his recently naviified
Marine goons on the massive deep sea
token hunting vessel eventually the
Raging battle creates enough structural
damage to the ship to cause it to flip
upside down throughout the rest of the
scene this of course lets the ocean
water flip the ship as it rapidly
capsizes and sinks with the family stuck
inside during this exciting sequence
there are many shots and situations that
are very similar to James Cameron's
previous action-packed epic set in the
ocean Titanic
speaking of James Cameron's 97
historical blockluster epic Titanic
another returning element from that film
is the director Casting Star Kate
Winslet as the mechanic Queen ronal in
avatar The Way of water Cameron often
likes to bring actors he's worked with
before on different projects such as
Bill Paxton appearing in Terminator
aliens true lies and Titanic as well as
working on multiple films with star
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Sigourney
Weaver
I'll be back however there had been some
tension between director James Cameron
and Winslet from their turbulent time
working together on the stressful and
disaster prone Titanic set luckily
they've since been able to bury the
hatchet and finally work together again
meanwhile ronal is a strong and powerful
character and she is the medkaena who is
the most wary of helping and giving
Sanctuary to Jake selly and his family
James Cameron's Avatar Series has often
been called a Sci-Fi version of
revisionist westerns like Dances with
Wolves and at play in the fields of the
Lord all these films have a sympathetic
view of Native Americans and their
struggles against violent and genocidal
colonization from European settlers but
they also usually show things from a
white person's outside perspective even
worse they often fall into problematic
white Savior and Noble Savage narrative
tropes with Avatar unfortunately being
no exception while Avatar the way of
water doesn't necessarily alleviate that
problem all the way the fact that Jake
Sully has been fully integrated for
years helps the narrative stay focused
solely on the Navy's own perspective at
the very least this includes more
backstory on the intricacies of the
politics between the various native
tribes of Pandora for instance there's
initially immense tension between Jake's
family who ails him the forest to
marikaya Clan when they first meet with
the Aquatic metcalina tribe its true
Avatar isn't entirely one-to-one with
real life history but this animosity
between the different Navi Clans is
reminiscent of how many Native American
tribes were warning with each other and
had trouble working together due to past
tensions during the European invasion
the tension between the matakaya and the
metcalina seen an avatar the way of
water is unfortunately also due to the
fact that like humans the navi can be
biased against those with physical
differences in the way of water the
metcalina navi have evolved seemingly
for thousands if not millions of years
to survive near the oceans of Pandora
which means that their bodies have
adapted specifically for that
environment this includes thicker
turtle-like forearms longer and thicker
tails and stronger diaphragms to swim
better meanwhile the forest-based Sully
family are more alive than thin to make
climbing and running through trees
easier Beyond those relatively obvious
physical differences between the forest
and water Navi another difference that
exists but is not really commented on is
the difference in skin color between two
tribes most likely due to the different
environments the mechaina's skin are
essentially like green while the sullies
are a much darker shade of blue this
adds an extra layer of racism and
classism to the movie's events it also
creates complications in mounting a
revolution since past bigotrys can make
it hard to bring disparate communities
to fight together against their common
oppressors even when it's necessary but
as the film shows at the end when King
tonawari says that Jake and his family
are now metcaina after they fight
together banding together and looking
past bigotry is possible
[Music]